sur un bonjour merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation alors aujourd'hui les
voyageurs sont moins nombreux le
personnel mobilisé les reste donc
limitée
avez vous des retours sur le chômage
partiel les méthodes d'intimidation des
techniciens de la sncf pendant cette
période compliquée oui dès le départ on
a eu des garanties de l'entreprise du
maintien des salaires en dehors des
d'avant des éléments variables
donc de ce point de vue là les cheminots
ont été plutôt protégé on va dire la
grosse difficulté c'est effectivement la
reprise d'activité parce que là on
navigue un peu à vue
voilà et on s'est pas précisément
comment passer de quinze mille salariés
actuellement au travail et revenir à 100
mille salariés avec l'état qui sont
assez lourdes
alors on l'avait dans notre sujet la
sncf menace de devoir supprimer des
postes
quel compromis défendez-vous afin de
limiter la casse nous on trouve
particulièrement malsain de parler de
suppressions de postes parce que pendant
le confinement il ya par exemple un
certain nombre d'opérations de
maintenance du matériel et d'opérations
de maintenance des voies de travaux qui
ont été reportés donc à la reprise du
travail on va avoir non seulement le
travail classique programmée et en plus
le rattrapage de ce travail qui n'a pas
été fait il va y avoir aussi énormément
de travail soit le service après vente
parce qu'il y en aura beaucoup d'usagers
qui sont dans l'inconnu sur les
réservations qu'ils ont pu prendre ou
les remboursements qu'elle devrait avoir
droit il ya énormément de travail sur
les conditions du déconfinement puisque
le gouvernement impose un seuil sur deux
occupés de le port de masque obligatoire
etc et donc ça ça nécessite une
logistique importante pour remettre à
plat les roulements de rames et un
certain nombre de choses et donc le
travail va être plutôt très important et
donc parler de suppressions de postes
alors qu'on sait que devant on a des
charges de travail roos c'est un
problème pour ensuite la question c'est
est-ce que le ralentissement de
l'économie
là la déflation ou lula où la récession
va amener une baisse du transport et
dans ce cas là effectivement c'est une
baisse du transport il ya moins besoin
de moyens
nous nous disons que d'abord il faudrait
quand même que l'état commence à mettre
en place des plans de relance
d'activités économiques plutôt que de
regarder comment on va supprimer de
l'emploi en fonction de la récession et
puis surtout si ce qui est dit sur le
fait de privilégier les modes
environnementaux protecteurs de
l'environnement est réel alors dans ce
cas là il faut faire en sorte que le
transport de marchandises ferroviaire se
développe même si l'ensemble du
transport on ne réduit il faut faire en
sorte transport collectif de voyageurs
se développe même s'ils entendent se
réduit et donc dans ce cas là on n'a pas
de logique
il faudra en créer ensuite on a supprimé
31800 emploi à la sncf depuis 2003 il
n'y a pas une année où on supprime pas
des effectifs donc le seul tabou a brisé
c'est celui leur développement avec leur
peau qui va avec
alors on l'a dit un le manque à gagner
est estimé à plus de 2 milliards d'euros
de chiffre d'affaires l'endettement de
la sncf menace d'être donc de plus en
plus important en fonction bien
évidemment de la durée de cette crise
sanitaire le pire scénario pour la
société et ses salariés c'est quoi c'est
justement la suppression de postes
balade à bord les deux milliards de
pertes ce ne sont que les pertes sur
l'activité ferroviaire publique en
france
vous savez que la sncf c'est un gotha
international et donc l'ensemble des
pertes du groupe c'est plus de 6
milliards d'euros au moment du début du
déconfinement donc clairement nous ce
qu'on souhaiterait pas dans un premier
temps c'est que on va dire la saignée
dans l'emploi public permettent de
compenser les pertes à l'international
ça c'est notre première préoccupation
le scénario le pire c'est effectivement
qu'on fasse payer aux salariés mais ça
c'est valable dans toutes les
entreprises 1 6 2
pour rétablir la situation l'état
apporte des aides mais quand tu rentres
en contrepartie à des milliers de
suppressions d'emplois dans toutes les
entreprises
alors on va vers une récession qui va
être durable et qui dit qu'il va
fracasser notre économie il faut qu'au
contraire les aides de l'état permettent
d'empêcher les suppressions d'emplois et
évidemment les faillites de manière à ce
que on a une économie qui s'en sortent
le mieux possible
ça c'est notre point de vue général et
ensuite comme je le disais si on
privilégie l'environnement il faut que
le ferroviaire soit aider à se
développer pour répondre à la hauteur
des besoins
le scénario le pire pour nous c'est
d'abord la mise en place on va dire des
dispositifs qui sont prévus dans la
réforme de 2018 parce que toutes les
architectures de financement de la
réforme de 2010 de repos de repos sur
l'autofinancement
par exemple l'état a décidé des travaux
supplémentaires sur les infrastructures
pour les financer il a exigé que sncf
voyageurs verse un dividende à sncf
réseau cette année on devait verser en
loin 660 millions d'euros
vous comprenez bien qu'avec une activité
économique nulle ou déficitaires ce
système là ce château de cartes il
s'effondre et tout un tas de systèmes
comme ça sont en train de se casser la
figure sur des réformes que nous on a
dénoncé justement par leur perversité et
qui révèle aujourd'hui lors leur
docilité donc le pire pour nous c'est
l'effondrement de ce château de cartes
et que l'état ne n'agissent pas en
contrepartie il faut que l'état change
les règles apportent de véritables
ressources supplémentaires
nous on parlait de d'affecter une partie
de la taxe sur les produits intérieurs
pétroliers ou d'autres peu importe mais
qu'on apporte des ressources
supplémentaires au service public des
vrais rosso merci beaucoup en tout cas
laurent brun d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
secrétaire général de la fédération cgt
des cheminots